- In order to belong in this
tribe, you have to conform,
and if you have doubts,
you're a dangerous person.
How many leaders have been
built up in these mega churches
that fall because the
pressure's just too much.
And as I look back, we were two kids
trying so hard to get it right.
My name is Lisa Gungor.
I'm a recent author, I'm a
musician and a songwriter.
My mom and I found this wild church.
They called themselves the Holy Rollers,
and from the moment you
walked in, it was loud
and people were running around the church.
I just think it's awesome.
So while a lot of people think it's crazy,
filled with crazy people,
I loved it and I was in.
I ended up going to college
and I start dating this boy
who's super Christian.
We get married really young.
We're too young to even rent
a car when we're married.
We didn't drink or cuss.
So we end up getting a
job at a really big church
in Michigan.
And this church was the
size of a mall, it's huge,
it was about 10,000 people.
We built a house out in the country.
They paid for our car, for our gas.
They paid for Michael's school.
We were 20 years old, and
we had this dream job.
We didn't have sex with each
other before we were married.
We waited to kiss, we did it all right,
we had this transactional ideal of God
and that's why we landed this
really great, awesome job.
We started trying to get pregnant
and couldn't get pregnant
and people would tell me,
well, just pray and believe.
Like, just say it and it will happen.
And I thought, I just don't
know how that can be true.
We were traveling the world,
we were going overseas
and playing to sometimes
60,000 people in arenas.
The more we ran into
other people's stories,
the more we started doubting
what we'd been given.
Michael and I took this trip in Europe.
From Rome, we took trains up to Krakow.
We visited the concentration camps.
We walked through the crematoriums.
And it's real hard to come back to America
and pray for something
when you have these images
of people's hair in piles and
children's shoes in piles.
Your ideas on what a good God is
can change pretty dramatically.
So I came back and found
myself trying to pray
for us to have a baby
or pray for our church
or pray for these different things,
and I just kept thinking
about the concentration camp
and how my whole perspective on my faith
has been a transaction.
If I'm good enough or if I pray enough
or if I believe enough,
then I get blessings
and I get a baby or a good life.
It's not how life is.
We all have this perspective
on who is in and who is out.
For Michael and I, that
began to change slowly.
You have to conform
and if you have doubts,
you're a dangerous person.
I remember looking around
going, what am I doing here?
What am I building with my life?
We realized we're no good
for this place that we're at
because our ideas had changed so much
and that we needed to leave.
I started weeping and
crying and freaking out,
going, what are we doing, we
don't know what we're doing.
Do you realize what we just left?
We left all of our security.
And we started becoming
heretics, you know.
We go up to Denver, we end up starting
a little house church in our apartment.
Our whole goal for it
was that it was inclusive
and that it was vulnerable
and that it was this place
that we'd always dreamed of church being.
More questions and more doubt
were arising for Michael and I.
Our heretic levels kept
shifting and changing
and kind of one-upping each other.
Eventually, Michael and I, we get pregnant
and I was really glad for that
because it didn't feel like
our daughter was this answer.
We really went through this
trial and this suffering
and now we're getting this baby girl.
Our ideas of God are deconstructing.
What is that we still believe?
But Michael looks at me and just says,
I don't believe in God anymore,
like I can't believe any of it,
and he just ends up talking more.
And I remember just
freezing in my whole body
'cause there's always been,
I was okay with the questions
but I wasn't okay with that.
I end up getting pregnant
again and we go through
a whole tour with me being pregnant
and for Michael, he feels
all this freedom in atheism
because he's not struggling anymore.
For me, I'm feeling all this anxiety
because I want him to
believe a certain thing
and I want myself to
believe a certain thing.
And I'm still just struggling
hard to belong and to be okay.
And I ended up having to quit a tour early
because I'm having, our baby's
having difficulty growing.
She's born a month and a half early.
She is just beautiful and
like with our first daughter,
we're both crying and
it's just this beautiful,
beautiful moment, and then she turns blue.
I remember this nurse
coming over and she's
shaking and looking really worried.
And she tells us our
daughter has Down Syndrome.
And so in the days that
follow, we find out
that Lucy has two heart
issues and she has to have
a heart surgery her second day of life
and then she has to have
another heart surgery
when she's six months old.
Everything really changed for me.
So I feel like this story
that I've been living
my whole life kind of came to this climax
with Lucy's birth.
When Lucy was born, we had
this huge social media blowup.
And there's stories in magazines
and all over the Internet
about our heresy, and we
were completely pushed out
of the church world, of this
tribe that we really loved,
and really painful and
devastating at so many of times.
Looking back on all of
it, I'm deeply grateful
for all of the things that happened
and I don't want what we used to have.
We live in a different head space now,
it's a completely different perspective.
And the connection I
feel with my daughters,
there's no us verus them,
there's no you and I,
there's no winners and losers.
Part of my dream is that
people wouldn't be so afraid
and so scared.
I know a lot of people are
still in this very conservative,
fundamental bubble and
they can be so afraid
to break out of that for fear
of what will happen to their lives.
And this happens in any religion,
so my dream is that we're not so afraid.
(contemplative music)
- Hey guys, we're Pero Like!
- Do you know it's
Hispanic Heritage Month?
(speaking in foreign language)
- For more Latino content--
- Subscribe here.